[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dure de longues secondes
à Bruxelles volodi mirzelinski et
chaleureusement accueilli par les euros
députés comme à son habitude le
président ukrainien livre un discours
combatif et demande une nouvelle fois
des armes supplémentaires à ses alliés
européens son message défendre l'Ukraine
ses défendre l'Europe
nous voulons défendre l'Europe face aux
forces les plus Antilles européennes du
monde moderne nous voulons que l'Europe
reste l'Europe et ceci est possible tant
que nous restons soudés merci encore
pour votre aide cette tête des Européens
volodime ski la souhaite plus importante
et surtout plus rapide
il peut compter sur le soutien de la
présidente du Parlement qui presse les
États membres de passer à la vitesse
supérieure
désormais les États doivent rapidement
envisager comme prochain étape de
fournir des systèmes de longue portée et
les avions de combat dont vous avez
besoin pour protéger cette liberté que
beaucoup prennent pour acquise
des avions de combat réclamés avec
insistance depuis des semaines par
l'Ukraine car il serait capable selon
Kiev de changer le cours de la guerre
mais pour l'instant Paris et
berlintemporisent
autre dossier crucial pour le président
elenski l'adhésion de l'Ukraine a lieu
il souhaite qu'elle soit effectivement
le plus vite possible mais pour cela le
pays doit se conformer aux exigences de
l'UE et selon Charles Michel Kief et sur
la bonne voie malgré cette situation de
guerre que vous affrontez vous avez
courageusement mis en oeuvre des
réformes nous sommes impressionnés par
les progrès qui ont été réalisés en
quelques mois seulement un soutien
politique au militaire qui doit être
maximale selon le président du Conseil
européen il annonce des prochaines
semaines décisives pour l'Ukraine qui
est qui redoute sous 10 jours une grande
offensive russe dans l'est du pays